I don't have to tell you --
I don't have to tell
anybody here. It's hot outside.
We're in the dog days of summer.
It's hot, it's muggy,
it's gross.
Everyone's dragging.
And that includes my writers.
You know, they write hundreds
of jokes everyday just to get
the 10 or 12 we end up
using in the monologue.
And honestly, a lot of the
jokes, we have to discard.
They just aren't good.
And sometimes I think
they wrote them just to
throw in a few stinkers
to meet the page assignment.
And just because the air
outside feels like dog breath,
that doesn't mean
we can tolerate laziness,
which means it's time for
another "Surprise Inspection."
[ Bugle plays ]
So here's how this works.
I'm going to read
some real jokes
that were really submitted
by my real writers
that are unusable for the show.
Some are dumb, some are
offensive, some are confusing.
Most importantly, the writers
don't know we're doing this.
And because most of them
don't watch the show,
they'll never know.
[ Laughter ]
So let's get started.
A fan has been banned from
the Colorado Avalanche's arena
in Denver after
he allegedly spread the ashes
of his best friend on the ice
at a game.
Even worse,
his friend is still alive.
[ Laughter ]
None of it makes sense.
That was Matt Goldich
who wrote that joke.
That's what he looks like.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I'm going to show
all their pictures
so that if you see them
in the street,
you're like,
"Let's go to the other..."
Today was the final day of the
Supreme Court's current term.
I'd say they went out
with a bang,
but most of them think
that's a sin.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
There's Ian Morgan,
who wrote that.
[ Laughter ]
The NYPD Bee Unit
over the weekend
removed about 2,000 bees
from a Times Square restaurant.
So now the restaurant
is just called "Apple."
[ Laughter ]
That's a good joke.
I apologize to Ally Hord.
We definitely could have
put that in the monologue.
Ian, on the other hand...
NASA, last week, released
the first full-color images
from its James Webb
Space Telescope.
So check it out if you wanna
see where my forehead stops.
[ Laughter ]
Mike Scollins wrote that joke.
Mister...
Mike wore a tank top to work,
so that's why we --
That's why we use that picture.
Authorities in Florida
arrested a pastor this week
after he allegedly masturbated
at a Starbucks.
Fortunately, they stopped him
before he could make any sermon.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
Now, there's a litany of reasons
that joke doesn't work.
One is, no one's ever
used the expression "makes..."
[ Laughing ]
Like, imagine if you said,
"I walked in on my son,
and he was masturbating."
"Did you come in before
or after he made some semen?"
[ Laughter ]
Who was the culprit
that wrote that joke?
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
When it comes to jokes,
he's got a type.
Irish airline Aer Lingus
this week canceled 18 flights
over two days
due to a spike in
coronavirus cases among staff,
leading the company
to implement a ban
on lingus between employees.
[ Laughter ]
Bryan wrote that joke.
Here's an interesting fact
about Bryan.
His best friend
on the staff is Ian.
[ Laughter ]
Probably called each other
on the phone.
"I got a good one
about lingus."
"I got a good one about sermon."
A customer at an Oklahoma
fast-food restaurant this week
found a bag of crystal meth
with their order.
"Hey, I only do powders,"
said Mac Tonight.
[ Scattered laughter ]
You guys remember --
Make some noise
if you remember Mac Tonight.
[ Applause ]
Alright. So the joke
was never gonna work.
[ Laughter ]
Also, "Hey, I only do powders"?
That -- Is that -- Has anybody
ever used that for cocaine?
"You want to go
do some powders?"
"Right after --
Right after I make some semen."
[ Laughter ]
"There's two things I like --
doing powders and making..."
[ Laughter ]
It's like
they don't speak English!
It's like they're writing
using Google Translate.
It's like they write the jokes,
then translate it to Japanese,
then translate it
back to English.
The fast-food restaurant Subway
recently launched a new menu.
"Well, the kid's menu
is not what you think it is,"
said Jared.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Two hand claps ]
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what's shocking --
is that a man clapped twice
or that he waited
for the groan to finish.
[ Laughter ]
He's like,
"I don't want my claps
to get lost in this groan.
I want everyone to know where
the two claps came from!"
[ Laughter ]
Mike Scollins wrote that joke.
The Ohio Supreme Court
recently suspended an attorney
for repeatedly driving naked
and exposing himself
to other drivers.
Or, as he calls it, "Exhibit D."
[ Laughter ]
Alright. This has been...
"Surprise Inspection."
[ Bugle plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]